welcome to the first lecture of this
class you may be used to having a first
lecture devoted to general comments and
motivating examples this one will be
different we will dive into the heart of
the subject right away in fact today we
will accomplish a lot by the end of this
lecture you will know about all of the
elements of a probabilistic model a
probabilistic model is a quantitative
description of a situation a phenomenon
or an experiment whose outcome is
uncertain putting together such a model
involves two key steps first we need to
describe the possible outcomes of the
experiment this is done by specifying a
so called sample space and then we
specify a probability law which assigns
probabilities to outcomes or to
collections of outcomes the probability
law tells us for example whether one
outcome is much more likely than some
other outcome probabilities have to
satisfy certain basic properties in
order to be meaningful these are the
axioms of probability theory for example
probabilities cannot be negative
interestingly there will be very few
axioms but they are powerful and we will
see that they have lots of consequences
we will see that the imply many other
properties that were not part of the
axioms we will then go through a couple
of very simple examples involving models
with either discrete or continuous
outcomes as you will be seeing many
times in this class discrete models are
conceptually much easier continuous
models involve some more sophisticated
concepts and we will point out some of
the subtle issues that arise and finally
we will talk a little bit about the big
picture about the role of probability
theory and its relation with the real
world